we're thrilled to have the day after
calling the game on CBS with the
Patriots beating the Rams Jim Nantz here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Jim I
am well and just like you I hurry home
as fast as I could so I just got on the
ground here in California and I'm
delighted to talk to you
I appreciate that Jim I appreciate that
well so what do you take away from Super
Bowl 53 Jim I can't I had very little
rest last night I relate to that I've
been of course circling in my mind so
many thoughts about the game it was so
bizarre odd strange unlike anything I
think I've ever seen in a football game
it's just it was it was just not what
anyone expected you know pay tip of the
hat here to Bill Belichick and I think
that was perhaps his finest finest hour
may be his finest game plan ever and I
don't want to shortchange while I'm at
at Brian Flores but we all know Bill
never gave away that defensive
coordinator title this year because he
is the coordinator and I was at practice
this week and I saw it at work in Flores
is right there with him but bill was in
the middle of it all
and I mean what a tremendous game plan
he put together to completely bring to a
screeching halt an offense that was just
packed full of power and speed and all
kinds of punch and it just was
non-existent how about this one yes we
had for the game one snap in the red
zone right for the game one and it was
the touchdown that was a touchdown run
by Sony from two yards out now tell me a
game you've ever seen that had one snap
from inside the 24 both teams combined
one I can't recall it feeble I know and
remarkably the it happened 53 minutes
into the game the exact number of Super
Bowls and played your numerologist dream
53 minutes into Super Bowl 53 is when he
creased the end zone Sony Michell and it
it really was one of those games
where I'm I was expecting and I assumed
you were to that at some point they
would just all the defensive filters
would be taken off and the the offense
would have its say but it really never
happened yeah I thought in the second
quarter when it was three nothing this
was still going to be somewhere in the
neighborhood of the game that my partner
Tony Romo had foreshadowed at the media
day he had been asked to make a
prediction on the game don't tell us
who's gonna win that the question came
from the floor we know you can't pick a
team but just can you tell us the score
and Tony said 2824 and the team that has
24 will have a ball at the end and be
stopped I thought that was still
possible I wasn't trying to call him out
on it or make it look bad on those
snarky people out there try to make
something out of that but the reality
was we had a game similar in flow at
Kansas City two weeks before and that
was a 14 nothing game and you never
would have imagined that it would be a
3731 final in the end that's what I
still thought we were heading toward was
a game they're going to be in the 20s
maybe somebody would touch 30 and this
thing would open up but it never did did
you get a sense at all because to me Jim
Jim Nantz here in the Rich Eisen show we
may never get an answer to the question
about Todd Gurley what did you glean
throughout the week about his
preparedness readiness health anything
Jim all I got was everyone told me he
was fine everyone on the record off the
record I think this is unrelated to what
happened in New Orleans I think the New
Orleans thing was about his focus or
lack of at the beginning of that game
the interception that bounced off his
hands another drop ball as the Rams were
going in for a touchdown could have
caught it around the 15 yard line
and I think it was never called a
benching I just think that McVeigh lost
faith in him in the NFC Championship
game a guy comfortable with the way
Andersen was playing now this one I
think this had to do with having the
game plan being taken away from it
not because anyone lost faith in him I
just think the game was forced to go in
a different fashion than what the Rams
usually do he still got whatever it was
10 carries in the game
not a lot but it certainly had no flow
to it
the Rams offense throughout and it's
just I think I just think those two off
performances are two different issues
and this one had more to do with what
you leaning on was throwing at him Jim
Nantz here on the Rich Eisen show just
landed back on the on the left coast I
think he's got an appearance on DP show
at Pebble coming up later in the week
kind enough to call into the Rich Eisen
show here the day after call in the
Super Bowl so let me ask you this one
Jim where does Brady rank I mean as we
all know you've seen great moments at
Augusta you've seen great moments in the
NCAA hoops tournament you've seen so
many great moments in your broadcasting
career out of those areas as well where
does Brady rank for you it's a very
difficult proposition to try to compare
Tom Brady to Tiger Woods for example and
how do you say one is better than the
other you know these are just such
special individuals who compete at such
a high level and who are just driven
insatiable appetite to try to win win
when they just never let go of it and
unquenchable thirst for victory and I I
just I admire that kind of athlete that
just it's never enough it's never enough
I mean you would have thought that maybe
this would be enough for Tom I can't
speak for him feel like I know him
pretty well you know I'm pretty well
we've covered him a long time but uh you
know he walks off that platform last
night with the Lombardi Trophy is little
girl in his arms is amazing I mean he
convinced me he's coming back I kind of
thought maybe there might be a little
wiggle room that if he wanted that this
might be the right occasion not not
necessarily on Sunday night but to take
away from the moment but I certainly got
a sense justice listen it's all
answering the questions that uh you know
he's definitely planning on coming back
and staying with that long-range plan of
quarterbacking till he's 45 years old
yeah I mean it's it's amazing I guess I
should ask instead of rank if you've
seen any you know similar traits and you
you mentioned one with Tiger I mean the
first time you handed that trophy to
Brady was way back when he was just
winning his second and now as you handed
that one to him last night you could say
it was the second most valuable trophy
that that little girl's in his arms for
him and how it all connects maybe for
him I think that that he wants to keep
playing while his kids remember watching
daddy win the Super Bowl
and and and prove how longevity is just
a mindset really and not an age Jim I'm
wondering what you think having been so
close up to it well let me speak up here
in terms of what Tom said to us when
meeting with them on the Wednesday and
that was discussed that when he first
had the Lombardi in his hands going back
to the Super Bowl in New Orleans Super
Bowl 36 beating the Rams who's 24 year
old kid didn't have of course a family
wasn't married and now here he is he's
you know he's a man he's 41 it's got
father of three got a beautiful family
and he said how much he enjoys being
able to share this with his kids his
oldest boy is really into it now they
really in it takes it very personally
with things you know Edelman fan more
than he is a fan of his dad but uh the
second son is is uh not quite as into it
and though and the little girl and I
made a reference to this on the Vickery
platform last night rich she's she would
always say that to Tom he said after the
game hey daddy I was cheering for you I
was saying Go Daddy go could you hear me
and he said of course I could hear you
and there's a father of a little girl I
just got a really sweet thing and to
have a little bit in his hand
like you said there's no trophy that
compares to that having a child in your
arms actually in a moment when it's the
greatest moment of triumph on the
football field merging with you know
your your greatest gift of all your
family so III think that he is to your
point I think he did this one thing is
keeping going it some people say hey I'm
gonna go spend more time I want to let
go of this and I want to I wanted to
both this all my time instead of
training and all that goes into it but I
think if kids are into it now I think
his kids are like enjoying this life and
watching their dad be you know the
greatest quarterback that games ever
known and last one for you Jim Jim Nantz
here on the show I really like Romo a
lot Jim I think you know and I've told
you this all fair I'll tell you here too
he's like the guy the guy at the bar
okay like think he reacts like the guy
at the bar he knows more than the guy at
the bar but he doesn't want to make it
seem like to the guy in the bar that
he's not smart as him I mean he just
he's he's he's terrific and all that I'm
wondering what it's like trying to get
the play in and get ready for the snap
and he's he's he's predicting stuff left
right up and down for you absolute total
joy I I just love working with him and
he is a regular guy who struck it big in
the NFL by working hard undrafted I said
to Sam farmer the Jose
you know Tony is a guy who carries
himself with a full-blown case of
undrafted itis so everything he's gonna
get in his world he's gonna work for it
whether it's being a great golfer or
being a quarterback who set all the
cowboy passing records or being a
tremendous analyst on television it
there's a part of it that comes
naturally but he's working it and he's
able to take who he is his personality
his boyish enthusiasm and be able to
appeal feel comfortable exposing that to
the world who he really is instead of
trying to pretend you somebody else
instead of playing the role of an
announcer he's just being himself and
we're we just have had a ball for two
years and so darn proud of him last
night
it was such an important show it always
is for anyone it gets a good fortune of
being able to work in any capacity a
Super Bowl but you know for Tony we
didn't have the best game it wasn't a
game too had a rhythm and flow so we
could get into it like the Kansas City
broadcast that we had but he did really
well and this is just the start of a
long great career that one day rich yes
we'll have him better known as the top
football analyst of his time than being
a quarterback for the Dallas Cowboys
well I mean I mean that's saying a lot
it's it'd be like Madden right that that
Madden was known more for that that's
the comparison in terms of John outgrew
his legend of being a Super Bowl winning
coach and became known as John Madden
the voice of the people the voice of the
sports and Tony's on his way so you're
you're on your way to pebble right
that's your next gig I'm on my way back
home we've got the golf tournament here
this week and Tony's gonna be here by
the way don't have some few dinners to
sit back and what about dollars and
celebrate what about Bella checks not
playing this your bills out this year
and I think Brady's going skiing so they
they've in the past they've somehow
they've come off of a Super Bowl game
and made their way to the Monterey
Peninsula to play in this thing but not
this year and then then the tournament
where I'm sure you'll be handing the
trophy to John Beilein
I'm looking forward to that that'll be
great spoken like a true Michigan alone
oh yeah maybe if it's not Calvin Sampson
at the University of Houston my school
right there I'm sorry yeah sorry about
that last year I just realized that too
but maybe see Zion it you know up close
and personal for that final four that
everybody's expecting it's a great next
few weeks Jim I look forward to it as
always you know it's all good fun I mean
you go from the Super Bowl to the Pebble
Beach pro-am and it's all a blessing and
I don't take it lightly we have to be
with you my friend Sam so much thanks
again you take care oh but you bet
that's Jim Nantz right here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience
you